Thursday night I took out Robin Fred and
his wife Alison Gary bababooey
Dell'Abate and his wife Mary and Benji
to dinner at a wonderful meal but I have
to say Robin Jesus so anyway we're
having dinner you're taking Top Billing
just today I'm gonna tell you so you
know Robin is a wine expert I said to
her listen Robin coming to give you the
wine menu pick out a wine for us to
drink and Robin picked out a beautiful
wine they served it was delicious and
the waiter comes over to me would you
like to continue with this - it sure
Robin picked it that you know that's
what she wants that's what will happen
that's why I sent him over to you I said
you asked mr. stern well sure I mean
absolutely was delicious we're getting
toward the end of the meal the waiter
comes over and he hands everybody at the
table an envelope I open up the envelope
and it's the actual label to the bottle
of wine to show you what you I've been
to Danielle a couple of times they never
do that I said uh-oh
what the [ __ ] is going on here why are
they giving me that maybe because they
know because my crew and it's important
to me Rob in order to wine now I don't
know where you grew up but actually I do
when someone says to you order a bottle
of wine listen to me
so you know this for the future I'm
alright with it I'm fine with it you say
to yourself okay what am I gonna order
here I have never ordered about the wine
list now he didn't look at the wine I've
been there a million times I know the
wine list there were bottles of wine
there that were $1200 all right were
there bottles that are a hundred or two
hundred dollars I was looking at the
French section so I don't let me finish
because I'm gonna teach you something I
know you know everything but let me
teach you one thing if I can and yo this
will stick with you even if you fight me
on the air about it so I get the bill I
went like this though
like like my breath yeah I went like
this Gary saw
they went out makes that face but let me
tell you so I had to add it up each
bottle of wine dough was eight hundred
dollars three bottles good wine bill
alone was over $2,400 I didn't keep
bringing it oh listen I figured I said
to myself Robin knows I figure you know
you know Robin we'll go order a two
hundred dollar bottle of wine oh did I
learn my lesson with you oh my god why I
even said that the better I said Robin
would have ordered that if we were at
the dinner I said I should just you know
she's filing for bankruptcy next week
you shoulda said Howard it's $800 a
bottle what are you saying that wine I
don't think I've ever had a $700 fine
this was 800 800 well that must mean I
knew things were a little pricey because
I ordered a scotch there before you guys
got there and the Scotch was fine and no
but the Scotch is a little pricier in
that joint than they are the whole night
without the wine would have run me about
I don't know 1,200 bucks or something
reason about the 2400 wrong jacket
options it went I know Robin said that
when the guy came back she said you have
to ask mr. stern but if mr. stern
doesn't know what the bottle costs of
course he would say keep it coming
because he thinks it's reasonable
there's an indication there when I send
him over look you better take a look at
it I was at the table and I missed the
signals you two had the indication have
any signal you're paying this bill but
how would he know now you'll never take
me out to dinner
all right don't punish me I will take
you I will never be taken by you again
that's what I hear I have never I don't
even look at the price when I take you
out I paid now Robert is very generous
with me but still when you go out to
dinner with a group of people you kind
of keep an eye on the price you don't go
800 a bottle you don't you don't I'm
just telling you for the future you
go 800 a bottle you just paid for dinner
I'm paying for the wine yeah I would
never accept it I will give it to you
and you're gonna spend thousands of
dollars on to give it to you and you're
going I'm just telling you for the feel
I don't care what you say I'm paying for
the wine